AND THE LAST ONE IS SOCK
PUPPETS.
I KNOW--
I KNOW IT SOUNDS RIDICULOUS,
BUT YOU'RE NOT GETTING PAID
UNTIL YOU DO IT.
PLUS, IT SAYS
IT'S A LOT OF FUN.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT IS
A SOCK PUPPET SAYING THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
REALLY TAKE HIS WORD FOR IT.
[ethereal music]
♪
OKAY, THOSE ARE...
GREAT, ACTUALLY.
SO LET'S USE 'EM.
- THIS IS SO DUMB.
I'M NOT GONNA DO THIS.
- DUDE, IT'S NOT ABOUT YOU.
OKAY? SOCK UP.
- USE THE PUPPET.
- FINE. THIS IS DUMB.
ALMOST AS DUMB AS NOT DRINKING
FOR AN ENTIRE WEEK.
- EVERYTHING
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO IS DUMB.
- AND FARTSI'S
A GENIUS IDEA!
- YEAH.
FOR ONCE, ADAM'S RIGHT, BLAKE.
IT'S TIME YOU GREW UP
AND PUT YOUR TIME TOWARDS
SOMETHING THAT'S WORTH SOMETHING
TO SOMEBODY
ANYWHERE ON THIS PLANET.
- GET HIM!
- DON'T TELL ME WHAT TO DO.
YOU'RE NOT THE BOSS OF ME,
YOU FAKE-ASS GROWN-UP.
- OOH...
- OH, I'M SORRY, MAYBE
IF YOU WEREN'T SO IMMATURE,
I WOULDN'T HAVE TO HOLD YOUR
HAND AND WIPE YOUR ASS FOR YOU.
- OKAY, THAT WAS ONE TIME.
AND I TOLD YOU, I'D NEVER BEEN
CAMPING BEFORE.
- HEY, GUYS, WHY DON'T WE
TALK ABOUT ME NOW?
- OH, OF COURSE.
WHO COULD FORGET YOU?
I LOVE HOW IT TAKES US
TO QUIT DRINKING
TO REMEMBER HOW SELFISH ADAM
"THE MAIN ATTRACTION" DEMAMP
REALLY IS.
- OH, I LIKE HOW YOU'RE USING
THAT NICKNAME
TO HURT MY FEELINGS,
BUT GUESS WHAT, ANDERS.
- YEAH?
- I LOVE IT.
AND I'M GONNA USE IT
ALL THE TIME NOW.
- DO YOU EVER STOP TALKING?
- YEAH, BLAKE, I'LL AGREE.
BUT AT LEAST HE KNOWS
HOW TO WRITE A RENT CHECK
ON TIME, LIKE AN ADULT.
- MM-HMM.
- OH. YOU WANT ME TO GROW UP?
YEAH, I'M IMMATURE.
I'M REAL IMMATURE.
BUT I'M IMMATURE
BECAUSE I KNOW, WHEN I GROW UP,
IT MEANS I'M GONNA BE
THAT MUCH CLOSER
TO MOVING AWAY FROM YOU GUYS,
AND MARRYING GIRLS AND STUFF.
- COME ON, MAN,
DON'T SAY THAT.
- NO...HE'S RIGHT.
[voice breaking]
I'M SORRY TOO.
I KNOW I CAN BE
SELF-CENTERED SOMETIMES,
BUT...
I NEVER HEARD "NO" GROWING UP.
NOW THAT I'VE LOGGED
10,000 HOURS OF BEING A BRAT,
I'M JUST A TOTAL
SELF-SERVING OUTLIER,
AND THAT'S NOT HOW ADAM
"THE MAIN ATTRACTION" DEMAMP
WANTS TO LIVE!
- OH, MAN. ADAM, LOOK...
[sniffs]
IT'S HARD TO SAY NO
TO THAT FACE.
IT'S A CUTE ONE.
- IT IS.
- THANK YOU.
- I KNOW I CAN BE
CONTROLLING SOMETIMES,
BUT IT'S JUST BECAUSE
I CARE ABOUT YOU,
AND I WANT THE BEST
FOR YOU.
BUT SOMETIMES I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S BEST.
AND THAT--
THAT SCARES ME.
- LIFE...IS...SCARY.
- I KNOW THAT I CAN
TELL YOU GUYS THIS,
AND YOU WON'T JUDGE ME.
I...LIKE...YOU GUYS!
- [crying]
I LIKE YOU TOO, MAN!
I LIKE YOU.
LET'S STOP FIGHTING.
- LET'S STOP FIGHTING.
I LIKE YOU GUYS!
- WOW.
THAT WAS INTENSE.
THIS BOOK WORKS.